hello everyone i'm literature for mit
today i'm going to present my joint work
with buddy
rari and the passing from google
research on distributing the
differential privacy and accounting
distinct elements
so here's the plan for today's talk
first i will introduce and motivate the
shuffle model of differential privacy
next i'll define and define the problem
of study
common distinct element problem and then
state all results for
it next i will talk about all results
for
selection and learning parity in the
shuffle model now i'll briefly
overview our techniques to prove our
lower bounds we introduced two
interesting techniques
the first one is moment matching from
the property
testing literature to the best of our
knowledge we are the first to apply them
in the study of differential privacy
second is the dominated protocols i will
define them shortly
and finally i will conclude with some
open problems
so so let's get started first let me
recall the definition of differential
privacy
suppose we have an algorithm m runs on a
data set
d constituted consisting of x1 to xn
and produces a probably probabilistic
output mm of d
and we say two data sets are neighboring
if they differ by at most one element
and we say algorithm m is epsilon
differentially private
if for all pairs of neighboring classes
d1 and d2
and all possible output z the
the the probability of m outputs
z is roughly the same under d1 or d2
the while and wireless notion means the
algorithm is private
because intuitively speaking
suppose that attacker a gets the output
of md
to and wants to learn something about
the ice using axi
we can even assume that the attacker
knows everyone else
inputs still the likelihood of
x i based on the attacker's information
being a and b can be calculated as
follows
and since these two data sets x
x minus i union a and x minus i
union b are neighboring the attacker
cannot distinguish them and therefore
that
it cannot learn anything about x i
and then the previous notion is called
epsilon pure differential privacy
and then we can relax them to to be
by allowing a slot tolerance delta
and then called approximate differential
privacy now
a very interesting setting of
differential privacy is the distributed
setting
well while the data set is not held by
only one entity
but instead of spread over many users
that is
imagine each user holds their own data
set x i
in initially and an algorithm runs the
data
x 1 2 x i and produces
a probabilistic output m of d
so how do i ensure the privacy of each
user
there's three important dimension one
wants to consider in such a setting
the first one is trust how much should
the user trust the curator
the curator is the agent who collects
the data and performs an algorithm on it
but the curator may have some motivation
which is hidden from the user
so that the user may may not want to
trust it
and second is utility of course we want
to want the algorithm output good enough
solutions for the given problem
and that's very important and second is
privacy
and third is privacy since we are in the
dp
region the extent of privacy can be
measured by the epsilon and delta
parameters
of epsilon delta dp
there are two ways to apply dp in the
distributed setting
the first one is the central model which
is the the most naive one
so each user hosts their own data
xi initially and then they just send
them
send their wrote data x i to the single
curator
and then they run f algorithm m on the
collector data set the
downside of this model is that after
sending your raw data to the
curator you must trust that integrity
for the rest of your life
it's not hard to imagine that some years
later the database
of the curator is hacked and the other
side is leaked
victim naked in fact such an information
leakage is happening all the time
so that so that's that's a price to pay
for this trust
in a local model instead of sending the
raw data
the user first applies a randomizer r on
the input
and sends the output of the randomizer
to the curator the curator runs the
algorithm on a message
sent by the users without knowing their
original data
so the local model
local model wants to ensure that even
the curator cannot learn anything about
the user data
so precisely we can define a local
randomizer r to be
epsilon locally differentially private
for all pairs of possible inputs and
b and r possible output z the
probability of
of r outputs z under a or b
are very close and similarly we can
define the absolute data
differential differentially private
algorithm as
as before by allowing some
tolerance of delta
so now let's compare these two models
for the most basic
aggregation problem in which every user
gets a single bit
and the problem is just to estimate the
sum very basic and simple
so for fear comparison we want to fix
the privacy requirement to be
constant epsilon and inverse polynomial
delta
this is the most important setting
so there are two two dimensions we want
to look at
trust and utility for the central model
the downside is that you have to
completely trust the the curator
but the good thing is that you can
achieve constant error
for the local model the fantastic point
is that you don't have to trust everyone
else
but you pay up you pay a lot for that
negativity
and the best error you can get is only
square root n
this may not be enough in practice
so a natural question arrives can we
have some mother which gets the best of
both worlds
can we get a constant error while
putting it as little trust
as possible in the curator this is
exactly the motivating question for the
shuttle model
which answers this question in
affirmative
this model was first started by ikos
back in 2006
in the name of anonymized communication
and is recently popularized by the need
of dp
differential privacy
that is the shuffle model only requires
the user to trust the shuffle
which which will be defined shortly and
while it's still
achieved constant error for the
aggregation problem
so very good
so what's sharper more precise more
precisely
recall that the following are the
pipeline of the local model
the shuttle model is an additional layer
of a shuffler
which applies a random permutation to
all the messages
sent by the users and the curator runs
the shuttle
version of all the messages without
knowing which users send
which messages in other words
it anonymize the messages
formally we have a local randomizer r
and a scheduler s
the transcript without that without the
outside d of x ones to xn
is defined as applying a random
permutation
and all the messages outputted by users
using the randomizer r
and we say a protocol is epsilon
differentially private
if for all pairs of neighboring data d1
and d2
and our possible output z the following
host
as you can see by just adopting the
previous definitions
and similarly you can define epsilon
delta differential privacy
another important measure for shuffle
protocols is a massive complexity
a user can send more than one messages
in the protocol
that is a r and r x can output more than
one items
these messages are treated individually
by the shuffler
and after the shuffling the curator have
no idea which messages come from the
same user
and the message complexity is how many
messages one user sends in the worst
case
which will sometimes be important
because you don't want a user to send
too much messages this can cause some
overflow in the network for example
so now we move to talk about our new
results
the problem of focus today is the
current distinct problem
the input and the input are just end
users each one holds their only
x i and the goal is to estimate the
number of distinct elements
among x1 to xn under the constraint of
being
epsilon delta differentially private as
absolutely a constant and they have to
be one
polynomial since we will talk about
several models will use with colors to
better differ
differentiated them what will screen for
the local model
purple for the shuffle model and the red
for the central model
and then in the central model is easy to
see that constant error is possible
one can just calculate the answer and
then
and that is some laplacian noise
and a first result is that in the local
model
we showed that the problem is maximally
hard in the local model
and our second result is in the shuffle
model
we show that the problem is still
maximally hard in the single message
worst case shuffle model and
surprisingly
our second result shows that if we relax
from the worst case message complexity
to the number of messages in expectation
then the problem becomes much easier
first for the local model we should have
no constant epsilon
one over n delta local db protocol
can solve current distinct with the
linear error
second we should have not only for
constant epsilon in fact
for some d equals n by polynomial
for lin lin d epsilon the problem is
still nearly maximally hard
that is the arrow has to be n by polar
login
and the surprisingly we finally see that
if we further increase the epsilon
funding d
to link n then the problem suddenly
becomes much easier
it can be solved by cancelled with arrow
square root
square root n note that mean d equals
link n minus log log n so it is very
close to linear
the first result is is pulled by
dominated protocol
and the second rather put by moment
imagine i would i will talk about them
when we get to techniques for the
shuffle model
we first show that for constant epsilon
and an inverse quasi polynomial
delta connecting current distinct is
still
nearly maximally hard for the single
message shuffle model
and next we should have if we allow each
user to send at most
half pass with o1 messages in
expectation
instead of worst case then the problem
can be solved by several
particles with squares root n arrow
hence that's the big gap between
messages
in worst case and messages in
expectation
to derive all new lower bounds in
shuffle model we provide new connection
between local and single message shuffle
model
that is we show that if our randomizer r
is constant epsilon inverse quasi
polynomial
delta dp in the single message shuffle
model
that is also linked n minus log
ling ling and epsilon inverse polynomial
dp in the local model combining this
new connection with our
local model lower bound we may
immediately obtain a
new load box in the shuttle model
rather obtain some new lower bounds for
other problems in the shuttle model
the selection problem is defined as
follows
there are end users each the ice user
gets a preference
vector x i of d dimension and
for each coordinate j the score sj is
defined as the
expectation of x i j and the goal is to
find out j star such that
s j star is close to the maximum sj
and the learning the learning parity
problems also is defined as follows
still there and uses an each and eyes
user gets a vector
s i and a bit bi and
the promise is that that exists a hidden
x such that
the inner product between s i and
x equals b i over 2.
and the goal is to find the hidden x
we shall we first show that constant
epsilon well one over n delta dp shuffle
protocol with at most k
messages for each user cannot solve
selection
your ends at the most d by k and
similarly
we show that such shuffle protocol
cannot solve learning parity
it will end at the most 2 to the t by k
plus 1.
all results are similar to the recent
work by
chill and almond they study a relaxed
version of shuffle protocol shuffle
model
termed robust shuttle model in which
protocols need to additionally satisfy
the
robust condition which roughly speaking
requires the protocol still be private
even if a constant small constant
fraction of users dropped out
this is a very desirable property in the
practice because
you cannot assume everyone is honest and
some some users
may be malicious and it
and they prove that constant epsilon
well and delta robust shuffle protocol
with unbounded messages
cannot solve selection of angst at the
most root d and cannot solve
if n is at most 2 d by n d by 2.
the remarkable fact about various laws
is that
they apply to the unbounded mathematic
case
where all results do not on the other
side all results apply to
even non-robust shuffle protocols and
also give lower bounds one case at the
most
and also give better lower bounds one
case at most root d
for selection as our bonus results we
also obtain lower bounds in the
two-party model
and resolve an open question we show
that there's a function f
whose global senativity is one yet
no constant f constant epsilon one will
end delta gp protocol for f in the
two-party model can achieve arrow
or and by login
since we don't have time to cover the
details check the paper for more on for
more on the definition and
this result is improved it improved
the previous one versus root n
separation
and answer the open question by a
previous work
now let us move to move to the
techniques
since the proofs are pretty technical
and long i will only
i will only show the construction of
holly instance
and also try to provide some intuitions
on what a lower bound should hold for
them
our first outbound builds on the moment
matching techniques that
that these techniques are first to use
are first used to prove lower bound for
the estimate
the unseen problem which can be seen as
the kind of distinct problem in the
query complexity model
that is you are given you are given
access to a
list a1 to a n and the problem is to
estimate the number of distinct elements
in the list
within an additive arrow epsilon times n
and with probability
99 and we are in the current complexity
model
that is each time one can adapt
adaptively
pick one element ai from the list to
curie
and the violin and variant proved that
and binocular curious are required
to solve its problem and also
and also sufficient later when a young
sharpen
and simplify their lower bounds and the
all proofs are inspired by one young's
techniques
so to put to prove all
so the key idea in what a young paper is
the moment matching
random variables as l to be log n and
the
lambda to be l squared that they they
construct two random variables und such
that
they have unit expectation and they have
they also have matching moments up to
the
logins that is for all integers
from 1 to log n the expectation of e to
the j
equals u to the j equals the
expectation of b to the j and still
they are they are supported on either
zero
or one to the lambda the most important
point about them is that u is mostly
zero
well b is mostly non-zero that is
u equals zero with probability at least
ninety percent
will be equal to zero with probability
at most ten percent
prove our result we want to construct
two distributions of
f of any inputs that are sets d to the u
and d
v such that no local
dp protocols can distinguish them yet
the number of distinct elements in q2u
and d2b differ by
d by 10. therefore combining these two
together will have the lower bound
we'll use the signal noise decomposition
to prove the
to prove a lower bound so the setting
here is that there are end users and
each one gets an input from one to the d
for some d equals and by point log n
and the w is that distribution over zero
and
or union with one to the
lambda that w is either u or b and the e
is a random subset of d such that
is at the most less that is at most d by
100
so we first construct the signal part
for each i from one to the d from one to
d
we draw a lambda i from w
and then we said n and language and i to
be lambda i
exactly and then we add another users
with input i
and also the construction of a noise
particle is that is
is that follow for each for each i in
the
in the set e we set n i
to be n minus t over the size of
e and then we add eight and i use this
with input i
and the construction of giveaway w is
just the
it's just that we draw two data d1 from
dw signal
and the d2 from dw noise and we output
their union
note that since the because u and v have
unit norm
d u signal has d inputs in expectation
and therefore d to the u and d to the v
has roughly
n inputs and the goal is to show that
is to show that
no local gp protocol can distinguish
them
we first talk let's first talk about the
purpose of the signal part
note that since that since
u is mostly zero is that this actually
means that
at a data set from tu signal with high
probability
has few distinct elements well
since v is mostly non-zero this means
that the number of distinct elements
in a sample from dv signal will be much
higher will be greater than 0.5 times d
also note that merging with dw noise
does not make a difference since dw
noise is
entirely supported on the small subset
of e
which has at most d by 100 elements
therefore therefore these two together
establish the second property we want
so we know detail u and v differ in the
number of distinct elements
indeed the previous construction does
not work as it is
and we have to apply a so-called
personalization trick
which is famous in the property testing
literature
so what's the poisonous poison narration
trick
well we first recall that the definition
of poisson distribution
is defined as follows that's a parameter
lambda and it's supported on
non-negative integers
the most important part is that the mean
of the
of percent distribution with parameter
lambda still lambda
and the trick is very simple in dw
signal
instead of setting an i as lambda i
exactly
we draw it from poisson lambda i
and similarly we'll do the same for dw
noise
we'll draw ni from poisson m minus d
over set of e
after this trick we can use the
fact that d and u have matched moments
up to the logins
to show that dw noise provides enough
noise so that
no local gp protocol can distinguish d
to the u
and e to the v combining these two
together all lower bounds approved
of course the real proof is is pretty
complicated so
but but also very interesting so i
so if you are interested in the proof
the details of the proof
you are welcome to check out the paper
finally let us talk about how do we
prove lower bounds we are dominating the
particles recall
the definition of local protocol are as
follows
and we and we consider an
about a notion called dominated
particles
where we say a randomizer r is epsilon
delta dominated
if that exists a distribution d such
that
for all x underneath e the probability
of
rx belongs to e
is at most e to the epsilon times the
probability of e happens under d
plus delta so
dynamic protocols are a special case of
local particles
because you you can just set d to be
x0 for for fixed x0 in
x then the the definition of local
particles just imply the protocols are
also dominated
our most important landmark here is that
if i is epsilon delta dp in the k
message
several several models on end users then
ice
is also epsilon plus k lin n delta
dominated
then we can put now we let me prove that
selection is hard for dominated
particles more precisely we show that
epsilon abs constant epsilon
well n delta dominated particles cannot
solve selection you answer at the most
d i think the over epsilon
and putting these two and putting the
connection
together with the lower bound against
dominated particles
we immediately get our lower bounds
for selection in a shuffle model and
similarly
we can improve our lower bound for
learning parity
finally we conclude with some open
problems the first one is whether we can
whether we can prove lower bounds for
unbounded messages in the shuffle model
without
robustness constrained
the result by chill and outman only
worked for a robust model
and all our bounds does not work for
unbundler case so this is a very
interesting question
also since our single message shuttle
model lower bank only works when delta
is
inverse quasi polynomial it will be
interesting to extend that to an inverse
inverse polynomial as well
currently currently it only works for
delta equals inverse quasi polynomial
we believe that the problem is still
hard when there are equals
one over polynomial but the current
technique seems
not enough to reach it and thank you
thank you so much for
your listening and happy new year